[Music]
my name is bilal i'm 42 years old and i
live in kansas city missouri
all right let's get into bilal and
shaida quick background info
bilal works in real estate he's pretty
well off financially he has a nice home
and he drives a mercedes-benz i do
appreciate nice things
nice suits
love watches
however at the end of the day you know i
didn't grow up in the suburbs i grew up
in a hood that really makes me who i am
valao has been divorced from his ex-wife
who he is still close with for seven
years and they share two children
together now let's get into his fiancee
shaida
she's 37 years old
she's a yoga instructor
and she's from trinidad and tobago these
two met the good old 90 day fashion way
online below said they had some mutual
friends on social media and she slid
into his dms
now i am here for a woman shooting her
shot but after his ex-wife said this how
do you guys meet
really just through social media brother
i know you be on facebook flexing and
all that i really don't yeah you really
do and how we're about to see shydah
behave
i'm wondering what is it about bilal
that truly made her interested
when you were on social media with her
what did you tell her if you told her
that you worked in real estate if you
told her that you're well off if you
told her all these things and then she
comes in you pick her up in that van
that's not yours she's you you go
through your shoulder because you want
to see what she really wants no that's
not her perception you said although you
you come off as a liar so she's gonna be
pissed off and be like some kind of way
so i can understand what you said but if
you said that in the beginning and said
you know what i'm this and i'm that i
got a truck i live in my childhood the
whole house everything and stuff and
she's i you could have been like okay
she really wants me for me but if you
solder on all those things and you do
flex like your ex tells you that you
flex even though you don't flex but you
flex like you show your your armani suit
you show what you got and then she sees
that and then when she comes off where's
all that then you're just a liar my
friend you're just someone that is
deceptive so it's not so much that she
wants just money is that you straight up
lied
so i just want to know what you told her
in the beginning
i'm sorry go ahead as a wise man once
said
if you use cheese as a trap don't be
surprised
if you get rats
let's fix
and you try to get if you try to attract
a [ __ ] with a [ __ ] you might
end up with dogs but anyways i digress
that's another bar
that's the back-to-back bar i know
that's really good the first bottle you
did was rip but this second one is
better yeah we have it on the shirt
do we
i'm mad at that i keep the same energy
when the woman on the previous video is
talking about i do test with men stop
testing your partners stop
unless it's an std test stop testing the
parking top okay and even though you
should be testing them you should go to
the doctor get tested okay
stop
testing your partners because once they
find out they're gonna be tested they're
gonna feel manipulated and lied to which
she's entitled to you talking about oh
my god why she is so mad
that's not the life you advertise
yeah
like said you come off as a [ __ ] yo
listen listen i'm gonna lie and
manipulate to you to see if you're
truthful and honest
by lying and manipulating her i'm going
to be violent with you to see if you're
pacifist
think about this logic about people
testing folks
that's just wrong so you just switch on
them you're a big old liar that's it
and we were talking and things were
reviving well and then i was like i have
to see you i have to see you in person
and that's when i made plans to to visit
her after talking to shadow for a while
over the phone balau went to meet her in
person for the first time in trinidad
the way you're dressed in trinidad my
guy
yo listen me the way you're dressed in
trinidad
doesn't look like you're driving in the
colony i understand so you're flexing
out there you got the chris shoes and
everything and stuff so the minute she
went yo it's exactly what the [ __ ] i
said so the minute she stepped in the
stairs like yeah i seen your watch i
seen your shirt
i know how many treads there is on that
shirt bubba
and after spending only seven days
physically together he proposed
it's 90 day people
it's 90 day
and get this due to covet in the visa
process it's been almost two years since
they've seen each other so you're even
facetiming her in a home that looks
completely different than the one that
you rock none of the walls
guys guys imagine if you get a girl you
meet online you guys are facetiming
everything's fantastic she's looking
fresh okay and fit whatever you want to
use
looking good okay
then you go to meet her in person and
all of a sudden she got an extra 75
pounds dusty as [ __ ] if you walk around
but you don't know it's a fat suit but
you're like yo what the [ __ ] is this
he's like well you don't love me for me
but who's the person i was talking to on
the phone all this time
what was going on it's like you should
love me in perspective
[ __ ] you've been lying to me you can't
fish me or some [ __ ]
you leave like i knew he didn't want me
rough it looks so
so dumb an important note here
throughout the entire time they've been
talking bilal has never shown her where
he lives or the car he drives
that's a cat because according to his
ex-wife he's flaunting on social media
we just seen this dude went to her place
down it so that means he flaunted his
wealth when he was down there
bunnies right here we are
[Music]
you take this
yeah did she get sad
[Music]
yeah
huh
i thought it was this one oh you thought
this no well you didn't put all you
didn't put my things in all this trash
what's that you didn't put my things in
all this trash what are you my mom huh
this is trash you put my bag inside
there like that that's not trash this is
trash
i think i see a little rock or something
that is my toolbox what are you talking
about
this place looking like something unsung
[Applause]
that's an old ass reference bro
that's a old ass reference
i want to get into my training behavior
and start to
behave like a tree you know we we start
to say bad things and we'd be wild yeah
that would be a good thing
but this is completely unacceptable
[Music]
i love you there but you're losing
points
you kind of lost little points for me
i'm a firm believer about appreciating
what you have
tlc y'all did her dirty you all did her
dirty you did her dirty that's what you
did because she's not gonna explain
you're not gonna have that other side oh
wow you did her dirty because now she's
gonna look like she's a gold digger or
whatever what not when she's not that's
not what it is wow i know i don't know
if she is yeah i i don't even maybe she
is a gold eager digger but i don't know
for sure because i know she's been she
feels entrapping right now all right
here let's find out yes all the food is
here yeah food is here
when milan came to trinidad he seemed
like a pretty much put together type of
guy you know he had louis vuitton
luggage
he dressed really nice dapa
so i was expecting the home to kind of
suits how he looks shadow goes on to say
she feels deceived by the lao
and she tells him she feels like he's
struggling and that has her worried but
once chada sees that her behavior has
balaal and his feelings she softens up a
bit
just a bit we might have to sell a
couple of those suits and i'm here to
work with him and so and that's a rather
die
because if i see that you're leaving
you're living above your means i'ma tell
you bruv we gotta sell some of this we
gotta sell some of the suit i remember i
remember yo my girl at some point didn't
know how much i was making and i wanted
to buy her a porsche and she was like
don't want to put that on the house and
i was like yes
that's what you're supposed to do
that's what you're supposed to do that's
what you're supposed that's what you're
supposed to do you tell me to put that
money in a house not a car yes
that's a ratta da if i see that you
leave if you see that you're living
above your means i'm gonna be like yo
yo
all of this flashiness is unnecessary my
guy wait
buying her a porsche is not living above
your means she didn't know
yeah okay that's what i'm saying she
didn't know that she didn't know how
much i was i'm you know i mean it's not
so in her thing i didn't show her the
numbers i was so i just told her we good
audience remember this is a sweet moment
basically saying like his wife is such a
wonderful person at least that's what it
appears like on the surface but really
he's just flop he's just he's just
he's just flexing on you poor [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying he could have got
her portions basically what are you
saying
yeah now let me flex anyway so i was
like yeah
you know what i mean
that's what you're supposed to do she
didn't know so i was like yeah okay
that's what's up yes
i mean i'm gay wait you're not supposed
to tell your partner to go into debt to
buy you a porsche
it always makes me laugh whenever you
see these these commercials about cars
and they're like there's always that
moment when the spouse comes out the
house with the wife and then they have a
brand new car and the girl's like oh my
god wow you took a completely uh
irresponsible decision without
consulting me and bought me a forty five
thousand dollar car thank you very much
so much for my birth
now i'm gonna have to work overtime
no people do that for rings too yeah
you need to stop but anyways yeah let's
go
we have a lot of work to do before we
could even cross the bridge of getting
married
i guess don't go with the image that you
carry yeah
then i and you can't you kind of fight
me don't be in shock
what do you keep saying an image what is
it
we came to try and never get a little
bit on baggage wearing expensive watches
and belts
and delta coming i mean in this little
humble boat it just it's not
how do you say it it doesn't suit you
i definitely wouldn't want to marry
somebody who just wants me for my money
i rather for 100 for sure want to marry
somebody who wants me for what i am all
right let me just stop right there um
listen a lot of this stuff is also
entertainment so don't take it too too
seriously but i'm just seeing everybody
comment on this stuff and be like gold
digger gold digger i'm like no that's
that's 100 not and also like guys
when you go to some of these countries
be it the caribbean's latin america all
these spots and you're rocking flashy
stuff don't be surprised when people
think you've got money
you don't even have to rock them much
to rock like you have
money they don't need to be named bran
but you were wearing name brands some of
the most vibrant and colorful ones so
louis vuitton when you say what image
i'm like bro there's no way you're this
dense there's no way possible
you cannot be he could not be in real
estate and not know what the [ __ ] is
going on come on dude but you guys want
like i'm a high value man oh so you make
a lot of money off this [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass why would you assume that i
make
y'all live whatever life you want but uh
as far as this thing goes like yeah they
did are pretty dirty i think and i think
the whole framing around this is making
her look this way is like nah this
dude's the shady one yep stop testing
your partners that's all i'm gonna say
it's funny because her name is shahida
and he's a shady one